Alhamdulillah.
for
[Silence]
Continuing where we left off in the book
of knowledge. The book regarding the
virtues of knowledge
in
authored by
knowledge
knowledge is a prerequisite.
It is a prerequisite to action
and it is a prerequisite
to the delight of our era
which is opinions
and
disagreements
etc.
These things are based and built on
knowledge. If a person
forms an opinion, this opinion is only
existent or valid if it is based on
knowledge. Knowledge of the Quran,
knowledge of the Sunnah, of the
messenger of Allah Sall. Wasam,
knowledge of the understanding of the
companions to that
Quran and Sunnah.
If a person does not have knowledge
but they have an opinion, they are
carrying the opinion of someone else
whether they know it or not. Most people
don't think this. Most people believe
and they're of the opinion that their
opinion is their own, that their choices
are their own. The only time a person's
opinion becomes valid and becomes their
own is when they have knowledge. The
prerequisite of knowledge. Otherwise, a
person is only carrying the opinion of
others.
In the virtue of knowledge, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
the virtue of knowledge. He says
subhanahu wa
verse number 11.
[Silence]
for
speech. for
men.
Now
[Silence]
for
here. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala uses a
sentence structure is very curious.
So the exact translation of this verse
verse number 11 of surah mujad he says
that which translates to Allah
will indeed raise those who believe
amongst you and those who have been
given knowledge in levels in levels of
esteem. Allah will raise us in levels of
esteem. What's curious about this? Well,
he says, "Allah will, does, and will
continue to raise those amongst you who
believe and those who have been given
knowledge." Those amongst us who have
been given knowledge, are they not of
those who believe,
they're the same, right? Those who
amongst us who have been given
knowledge, they are part of the group
that believe.
But Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
them specifically
in order to articulate their esteem.
In order to articulate their esteem for
instance Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
in Bakar
he says
for
[Silence]
dun.
For instance, Allah uses the same
rhetoric
in a lot of places in the Quran. An
example of this inah Bakar Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala says
be mindful and diligent in establishing
the prayers and the middle prayer
specifically.
The middle prayer
in the correct opinion is part of the
prayers but he mentions it after already
mentioning it in a general sense. He
mentions it specifically in order to
articulate what its importance.
It's as if I were to say
be careful with these groceries and be
careful with the eggs.
The eggs are part of the groceries,
right? Yeah, but what do you understand
from this sentence structure?
Be extra mindful of the eggs because
they are very delicate, right? We use
this in our day-to-day speech. And so
the point here is that Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala mentions those who have been
given knowledge amongst us
and he mentions the people of belief in
general but the people of knowledge
specifically
as if they are a different breed as if
he is speaking about the lions and the
men. The regular men they're good but
then there's the lions over here.
They're very specific type of people
amongst us that have very specific
esteem and levels. I have a question.
Is there a difference
between us
the believers amongst themselves?
Is there a difference between them?
[Arabic recitation]
Yes.
Right? Allah says,
"Aren't the believers the same? Even the
messengers,
correct? If you said yes, you're wrong.
And if you said right yet no, you're
also wrong."
Meaning in one respect, all the
believers are the same.
But in another we are vastly different
because Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us
Allah has given
esteem to some of you over others.
as a human being,
as a person having a soul, we're all the
same, right? We're all brothers.
But that is in a vacuum. In theory, in
practice, there's a big difference
between us. You cannot treat a king like
you treat a peasant. You can't do it.
And the idea that there are no kings in
Islam is a very faulty idea. This is an
idea which was mainly introduced because
of communism you know and you know
this western propaganda of the freedom
fighter. We want the freedom fighter
just not in America. We want freedom
fighters all over just we don't want any
here. Here here we don't want freedom
fighters. Right? And so we set the rest
of the world on fire.
Whilst here we practice a very very very
different set of laws. We need to spread
democracy throughout the earth. Everyone
has a right to choose. Right.
Sure. As if we are choosing here. Maybe
we're choosing the county commissioner
of Puma County. Sure. But
lobbyists
and organizations and money, that's what
chooses. Not elections, not your vote,
not your vote, not mine.
This isn't a conspiracy theory. It's
just not possible for these things to be
left up to random chance and the
influence of the masses. We don't have
that. that would introduce nothing but
lawlessness.
And so the point here is that is there a
difference between people? Absolutely,
there's a difference between people. It
doesn't mean that a rich man is better
than a poor man in belief. No. In
belief,
the best of us is the strongest of us in
belief.
However, there is a difference between a
king and a peasant. There's a difference
between a slave and a free man. There's
a difference between a man and a woman.
There's a difference between the old and
the young. There's a difference between
the ambassador and the worker.
There's a there's a difference between
the master and the apprentice. There is
a difference and we embrace those
differences,
right?
And so the point here is that the
greatest in esteem amongst us worthy of
mention are the people of knowledge.
They are at the top of that hierarchy.
They cannot be bought. They cannot be
paid for. They cannot be
urged. They cannot be put onto a
bandwagon. If they are truly people of
knowledge
they transcend by their knowledge that
and this is why the people of knowledge
they don't wear specific clothes they
don't wear specific symbols right so
that knowledge is the only thing that
proves a person as being part of that
community
no one can you know swindle his way
in. I'll give you a story. We'll end
with this.
[Arabic recitation]
you know when whenever a pope dies
they have all of the cardinals and the
high ranking in the Catholic Church.
They all go back to Rome and they sit at
the Vatican and they convene and they
vote as to who they want the next pope
to be, the next person to bless all of
the world. So they're giving him the
power to be the pope and then he is able
to forgive humanity. I don't know how
that works but anyways
side issue.
So while they were having these
meetings, these meetings are extremely
extremely extremely
strict as to who can attend these
meetings. There's a lot of speculation
and politics going on, the press, the
media, none of them are allowed. So all
of the cardinals and all of the
highranking, you know, people in the
Catholic Church come and they this last
this last time when they when Pope
Benedict left and they were voting in
this last one, they had a guy that was
not a cardinal. He bought the guard and
he bought all the, you know, the red hat
and everything. He attended those
meetings for more than 20 days
and nobody knew that he was not supposed
to be there. He sat at the table, he
made vote, he voted with them, etc. He
was just a guy. I think he was from New
Jersey if I remember correctly.
How can this happen? How can this
community be infiltrated with a
Halloween costume? Because
that is all it is. It is a position. The
person who holds that position does not
have to be a person of knowledge in
order to sit there. If if a person who
is not a person of knowledge were to sit
for instance with the council of major
scholars in Saudi or
and sit at that table in 5 minutes
they would immediately know that this
person is not supposed to be here
immediately because people of knowledge
are recognized by people of knowledge.
We don't have symbols. We don't have
particular colors or garb.
We don't have these things so that we
don't judge one another based on
superficialities.
We
look at substance and we judge based on
substance. These other things they are
merely images. As the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam says
Allah in judging you does not look to
your images nor to your bodies. Rather
he judges you based on your intentions
[Arabic recitation]